what men want the idea here the concept
here is that you get to hear what men
are really thinking yes is that's
something that you would want to hear
that real life
no thank you no you think it would be a
curse a curse yeah yeah I I've too many
voices of my own rattling around in his
domes I don't need the pressure of
someone else's right only my dog my
fiance and my son oh those are voices
that you want to be yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't mind particularly my dog yeah
I'm kind of figure out my fiance my son
but my dog I really it's hard to just
you want to know what he's thinking
yeah what about you Tracy can you relate
you don't want to be at my head crazy
[Music]
first of all you don't hold anything
back you know exactly what's on your
mind so we don't need that game you
remember the old Star Trek yes oh wow
yeah you are
remember the episode when you had to
have white you have black characters
jasny jump and it was running like this
all day playing to my head
[Applause]
exactly what you're talking about you
see okay with it I'm good with it yeah
they wouldn't be yeah so Tracy you don't
want and you don't want to know what a
dog is thinking either no no I just
if I knew anything I just want to know
that the women in my life my wife my
daughter my mom's my grandmother or my
all the women are happy and satisfied
with me as a man and a person I like
that it's medallion is a number one dad
my kids bought it for me and they used
my money your kids spent your money and
got that that was the thought that
counts also you should've thought about
buying some cheaper